Hong Kong's chief executive is urging
pro-democracy protesters who've
barricaded themselves inside a
university to leave peacefully Carrie
Lam has also asked police to treat them
humanely
it's believed around 100 protesters are
still inside officers have surrounded
the campus and are arresting anyone who
emerges we will use whatever means to
continue to persuade and arrange for
these remaining protesters to leave the
campus as soon as possible so that this
whole operation could be able to end in
a peaceful manner and lay the basis for
the subsequent work by the police to
stop violence in Hong Kong let's go live
now to rob a bride who's outside the
University Rob so we've seen this steady
stream of students coming out of the
university just bring us up to date with
what's been happening there Rob
that's right Darrin this whole process
has been going on there throughout the
day from first thing this Tuesday
morning we're now into the afternoon
here it has to be said maybe in the last
couple of hours the flow of people
coming out has slowed somewhat we see
one or two every hour or so now coming
out and there is a distinction in how
they are treated those students who are
over 18 who are going to face arrest and
prosecution and the courts coming out to
score to by police are taken to waiting
police vans sometimes with risk ties on
but a good number of the students coming
out are under 18 and they are being
their details are taken there might be a
further action taken against them but
for the meantime they are released into
the care of their parents or guardians
and escorted away and it has to be said
that some of those under 18 year olds do
look incredibly young those seem to be
barely teenagers in fact we do know that
of the 600 students also who were in
here who have who have either escaped or
have had not been now been taken away
around 200 or so were under 18 as you
heard there Carrie lamb the chief
executive wants the students to be
treated humanely and to be seen to be
treated as humanely as possible in the
hope of defusing this whole situation I
guess there probably are maybe in the
tens or dozens of PF students still left
inside the concern for the authorities
here is that those are students are
leave here because of the longer they
remain then there is the danger as we
saw last night Monday night our four
other protesters to take to the streets
in support of them leading to fresh
clashes with their police Darren and Rob
this was a sustained standoff with the
police wasn't it so what's the mood like
among protesters now and what happens
next
it is still very polarized tension
tensions you can still feel a certain
amount of tension in fact as you get
some of these students being released
there are shouts from some of the people
living nearby in support of them so it
certainly has exacerbated this whole
situation has become almost a rallying
point you you sense for some protesters
so the authorities will hope that with
this episode now seemingly drawing to a
close it will deescalate things it will
take some of the attention some of the
heat out of this whole situation because
of course we are in a very important
week here in the run-up to district
council elections that come up here in
Hong Kong and as I say those words it
doesn't sound very exciting these are
people going to vote for their local
district council as a local election but
it is being seen as a referendum in the
in the current debate about Hong Kong's
relationship with China the autonomy and
the answer and how much autonomy Hong
Kong shall be allowed so it's a very
important it's a very important vote and
the people who are doing the protesting
either peacefully or not so peacefully
will be very conscious that the more
violent the protests become the more
unrest there is the greater the danger
will be that the authorities might say
they're going to have to postpone that
election Darren all right to rob a bribe
there in Hong Kong for us Rob thank you